não seria a vida muito mais
extraordinária encerrar nos trouxe
esperança entusiasmo e sempre foi assim
nós tivéssemos a certeza que significava
que alguém estava província serão
tornados pequenos erros do dia a dia
como quando esquecemos a chave de casa
estamos atrasados para um lado e nos
enganamos no caminho eu vou falar daqui
os erros que marco na história das
nossas vidas
quer dizer eles que ficam gravados nas
nossas memórias por muitos e muitos anos
principalmente quando pensávamos que
estávamos a fazer tudo com meras por
tirar o nosso melhor e mesmo assim as
coisas não correm como elas prazo como
por exemplo quando conseguimos o emprego
dos nossos sonhos e não podíamos ter
mais qualificações ou até mesmo quando
ficamos a nossa vida é uma investigação
quem insista em não dar resultados
significativos ou até aquela relação que
os visitantes e que acaba por terminar e
razoavelmente mas sabemos que ser
precursora evitava se eu pergunto mas e
se fossem o bilhete certo para uma
viagem com o poder de mudar as nossas
vidas
é por isso que eu vim hoje para vos
convidar errarem comigo em 2013
eu tinha acabado de chumbar a 24
créditos quando só poderá chamar a 15
eu era um estudante sina no segundo ano
de faculdade e quem acabou de chumbar o
ano o logo no primeiro semestre
como é que é possível e não conseguir
acompanhar a matéria quando eu vou fazer
tudo com os meus colegas faziam quero
estudar muito
durante muito tempo e assim ser aquilo
em que acreditava que era
verdadeiramente boa a estudar então
porque não estava se sentindo se
lembrarem da uma vez em que erraram e
olharam para as vossas vidas e começaram
a questionar tudo que eu fazia sentido
então sabem que a vontade que sentimos é
fugir e até fugir um cinto e banho longe
de um lugar onde ninguém que conheça
mas quantas vezes é que sentimos vontade
de fugir mas significa produtivo chumbar
bom tanto que eu sou que não podia
continuar na que o curso não fugisse
mesmo eu precisava perceber ser um filho
que eu queria continuar a fazer
aliás eu tento fazer aquilo que você
vale a pena e foi por isso que eu não ia
seguir por ter repetido as cadeiras que
faltavam
eu decidi fugir para a irlanda e no
final de fevereiro de 2014
eu estava vivendo uma pequena cidade
chamada como isto é aquelas irá como
esperança enorme viver um sonho irlandês
eu sonhava em trabalhar no café servir
as mesas não pague a fazer imensos
amigos e acontecerá que o país inteiro e
ter tudo vale a pena e eram as montanhas
verdes da irlanda que eu responder a
todas as minhas dúvidas em um cantinho
edições da volta daquela cidade e quando
já não viam mais empregos por concorrer
nem sítio vão deixar o meu currículo
tenham passado dois meses dois meses e
eu continuava desempregada
minha esperança deu lugar à frustração e
como eu já não tinha mais para sustentar
o meu desemprego eu tinha duas opções
voltar a portugal com uma missão a
cumprir
ou então podia candidatar a um emprego
que eu tinha decidido ignorar porque não
fazia bem para o meu sonho irlandês o
brasil até duvidava conversar com alguém
que pudesse fazer aquele tipo de
trabalho mas como estava decidida a não
desistir
talvez cai e surpreendentemente passado
uma semana já tem um emprego a tempo
inteiro
até parece que as coisas estão a
resultar o problema foi passado dizer
que desistir
a única hipótese que aquela fuga não
estava a dar
era uma fábrica de carne congelada
ficaram presos em água congelada
a única hipótese que eu tinha era fazer
o turno da noite é trabalhado o instinto
de tatu às quatro da manhã numa câmara
frigorífica onde quase todos os meus
colegas eram da europa
no oeste o que o que significava que não
percebia rigorosamente nada do que os
vizinhos o dia nas mãos do meu trabalho
era embalar 800 carros por minuto e as
pernas porque o torneio à frente sempre
em pé é que eu era pior que chumbaram
como era possível eu estar ali se eu só
queria respostas até que ter a coragem
de fugir como é que é possível voltar a
fazer o que eu trabalho aqui é tão
injusto e um dia que eu cheguei em casa
a chorar e eu pensei eu tenho existir
num e não consigo fazer isto e por tanto
tempo sem marcar um bonito alta para
portugal mas por algum tempo uns 60
equador desistir é muito maior que a dor
tinha nas mãos
minha cidade respostas era muito maior
que a frustração de saber que não era
que o trabalho que eu queria fazer e por
isso decidi voltar mais une só pra ter
certeza
depois não me arrepender depois voltar
nos ea síria e no outro até que percebi
que afinal é que os meus colegas eram
imigrantes como eu e até mesmo para ter
admirado por isso se ele tentar mais um
dia e outro depois é música na rádio era
aquela que eu estava então tem outro
game e outra até o dia em que decide
para mim próprio que era ali que eu ia
ficar até onde estava destinada a votar
e foi como por magia de repente eu
preciso que você já tenha menos um
processo continua até hoje estava
naquela linha de empacotamento dava um
tempo suficiente para começar a adquirir
outro lado do ituano do russo todos
somos diferentes e eu já tava falar eu
já começava a compreender alguma coisa
do que eles diziam mesmo assim
continuamos entendendo a coisa até que
descobriram a irlandesa e com quem
praticar o inglês e pode parecer
estranho mas embarcaram começou a ser
divertido e o conceito mesmo a
embarcação ea zte já não dava um caixa
de cartão para fazer
etiquetas popular e não imaginam o
quanto é incrível com a etiqueta salvo
cidade alguns nomes de montagem
eu trabalho repetitivo tornou-se
meditativo eu consegui relaxar e ficar
grata e foi o que eu percebi que não era
as montanhas verdes que responder às
minhas perguntas era aquela fábrica por
dia numa irlanda e o final estava vivo o
meu sonho irlandês
eu percebi que ser frio naquela fábrica
eu já fui em qualquer lugar fazer
qualquer coisa mas ao mesmo tempo sabia
que queria muito fazer medicina e queria
muito voltar para o meu país eu tive a
certeza que no último dia é aquela
fábrica tinha ficado como o
perfeccionismo meu stress mas minha tia
do coração
então este um bar foi por isso que eu
fui padilha foi só quando voltei pro
futebol clube porque tinha um bar quando
conseguem fazer todos os exames na
primeira fase com as notas cria eu
percebi eu andava a estudar mais
eu queria passar e tudo drasticamente o
tempo de estudo
mesmo continuando a ver os meus colegas
estudaram muito
durante muito tempo eu soube que esta é
a resposta certa pra mim ele ache teve o
coração cheio ea mente sem estresse era
um segredo pra fazer os exames de forma
altamente eficaz mas isto foi rodado foi
prudente nem tinha surgido a crença que
chumbar era incrível e por isso nenhum
exame conciliar sua história e esta foi
a minha bênção
e hoje há dois meses e retornar à
américa e torcer foi dos exames da
primeira fase com as notas que cria e do
miami viagem como bem sucedida e
portanto se um bar foi um grande erro
foi uma grande viagem e foi uma grande
invenção
eu acho que é 300 uma receita para
podermos errar com sucesso pela própria
da próxima vez precisamos olhar os
nossos erros para o curso com esperança
e entusiasmo de saber que guardam ao
extraordinário e primeiro da jato já
acho que já deu para perceber que é
preciso fugir nem que seja fugir da
rotina e talvez as mesmas coisas que
sempre fizemos não seja o suficiente
porque a vida está a exigir um nível
o massacre foi suado nós mesmos e é
claro não é preciso ligar basta fazermos
uma mudança grande o suficiente para
fazer uma viagem entre nós próprios
em segundo lugar o caminho do edifício e
por isso temos que persistir por tornar
se muito mal em se tornar incrível e
precisamos ter confiança no processo
em seu lugar temos de aceitar a bênção
do que as nossas respostas até podem ser
muito diferente do que os deputados têm
até parecer pouco convencionais mas
estas respostas são aquelas que são
certas para nós
ele até pode sempre trazer dor mas pode
ser muito diferentes nós só vemos que
vai trazer mudanças profundas as nossas
vidas e tenha certeza vai trazer muito
mais do que achamos que temos à procura
nós temos de deixar que o erro nos
mostra vida extraordinária que esconde e
por isso pergunto o que será que você
vai gostar tentar mostrar a brigada já
passou essa experiência com seus colegas
com algo assim o resultado ficou muito
surpresa para nós não faria caducar mas
eu acho que aqui é que o que eu não
tenho mais é procurar outra parte de
relaxar e de várias coisas como essa
contratação é e as pessoas ficam acho
que deseja nesse aspecto acho que essa
experiência acho que ajuda na minha
agenda está obrigada
[Aplausos]